so if i had to use one word to describe
ai today it would be
surreal
it's kind of hard for me to imagine that
10 years ago it was very much an
academic endeavor and now countries are
forming national strategies around they
are what
so the ai index
is a project that aims to track
the status of ai and each year they
release an annual report
um here are some quotes from this report
compute doubling every 3.4 months um the
conference neurops
increased over 800 percent in the last
eight years number of jobs is also going
up and so quantitatively at least we see
that you know shouldn't be surprising to
people that ai
is just becoming a big deal
qualitatively
what
i think is really interesting is that ai
is transitioning
from being in the lab to the real world
for a long time ai was limited to
relatively artificial environments which
was useful for developing
methods
but now we're seeing real world
deployment in ways that really impact
people's lives
and i want to stress that ai
like any technology is an amplifier it
makes what is good better and makes what
is bad worse and we really need to be
aware of both sides
so let me start with the positives the
prospects
so here are some examples in which ai
has been well beneficial so in the last
decade speech recognition question
answerings have gone
remarkably good and now you can talk to
your favorite assistant and expect some
basic though obviously not perfect level
of language understanding my
three-year-old is growing up thinking
that talking to computers is perfectly
normal
and you know search engines like google
have told us
that
you know enabling
power comes that comes with um
being able to tap into the world's rich
information and now taking one step
further these assistants allow uh this
information to be more efficiently and
naturally accessible which could be
especially useful for people do not have
the means to use a computer
so there's language barriers in the
world that pose significant
significant challenges to travelers
immigrants
businesses minority subject communities
and so connecting people is very
valuable so machine translation aims to
overcome these barriers
machine translation has come a long way
since the 60s and while it's far from
perfect it is really good enough for
someone to get the basic gist of a
document written in a different language
or to have a real-time conversation with
someone speaking in a completely
different language
autonomous driving will someday
hopefully be able to reduce the number
of accidents and congestion but a major
challenge is to recognize what is going
on in the unstructured environment and
computer vision has
made a lot of progress towards
recognizing these objects but
there is still headroom to be made to
ensure sufficient
reliability an interesting application
is visual assistive technology so this
is an example it's called scene ai for
microsoft research would you point a
camera at something and it narrates um
what's going on there and so this
obviously could be a game changer for
the visually impaired
auto capturing technology is the
opposite which it's also potentially
very impactful turning sound into sight
healthcare is another big area that's
growing in importance
both for diagnosis and therapeutic
development especially in areas where
there is a shortage of
clinical expertise
so an example of this is
detecting
diseases based on chest x-rays or
diagnosing diabetic retinopathy
which is a you know one of the major
challenges in ai and health care these
days
there's also interesting recent data set
that
shows images of covalent 19 cells
infected uh
the 19 infected cells
and how they respond to certain drugs
with the hope that one day we can find
drugs that can uh
treat late stage cover 19.
poverty is a big a problem in the world
and but even figuring out
the areas in greatest need is
challenging
so some recently people have been using
satellite imagery to try to
figure this out because gathering survey
data on the ground is
very very expensive
and using machine learning you can look
at satellite images and try to predict
various wealth indicators this could be
really useful for governments and ngos
to take action and monitor the progress
so this sounds all great right so what's
the catch
well there's a lot of things
that one has to be aware of we'll
give i just want to give you a general
idea of the space and i'm going to go
fairly quickly here
first is energy consumption
so there is a genuine cost to training
high performing models that we're seeing
today
so if we look at nlp
there has been a trend of training more
and more large language models back in
2018 which is like ancient history now
models had about 100 million parameters
only
and then bird came along which some of
you might have heard of of a big splash
with 300
and then in january this year
microsoft released a model which was 17
billion parameters and then to top it
off open ai may release 10 times
larger model with 175 billion parameters
so this is
big
um last year there was a paper published
that talked about the carbon footprint
of training these models they looked at
transformer with 200 million
uh parameters which would be around
here on this on this on this graph
and they show that even this train if
you use neural architecture search this
was five times
the amount of co2 emissions in the
entire lifetime of the u.s car
so now i'll leave you to speculate how
much dpd3 uh what gp 33's environmental
footprint is
so needless to say a lot of people are
actively trying to somehow reduce the
model's
size um
improve efficiency without sacrificing
accuracy
privacy is another big area so
machine learning algorithms have really
been developed to assume that data is
just sitting there in one place and is
fully accessible
but
our mobile files generate a wealth of
information and we might not want to be
sending all that information up into
some big internet company
recently there's been a lot of active
work in privacy preserving machine
learning which allows some of the
learning to be happening on device in a
centralized way and only transmitting uh
various essential statistics to a
central server
security is another major uh challenge
especially in high-stakes applications
like autonomous driving and face
identification
for authentication
so here models not only need to be
accurate but robust against attackers
and malicious behavior which we know
exists in the world
so researchers have shown that if you
can adversarial examples so if you take
us images of stop sign and you actually
post these stickers on them you can get
a state of the art
system to think that these are speed
limit signs
or you can actually buy these cool
looking glasses that will trick face id
to think that you're some celebrity that
you're not
so guarding against these attackers
quite kind of frightening is still a
wide open problem
um bias was mentioned in the chat
um this is something that's maybe less
uh spectacular
in terms of
you know sudden impact but i think it's
more pernicious so here's an example
from machine translation if you take
hungarian
and you have the words he and she which
are not differentiated you translate
them into english
so the machine translation model has to
hallucinate the gender you can reveal
all sorts of stereotypes that the model
is harboring for example she is a nurse
baker wedding organizer but he is a
scientist engineer and teacher and ceo
and there's a lot of active work showing
how
hard it is to actually remove these
biases
so i want to say that
machine learning algorithms they are
based on
quote-unquote objective mathematical
principles but
the trained models are trained on
uh to latch on to statistics in the data
and the data comes from society so any
biases
in society are reflected in data and
propagated to model predictions and
worse sometimes they're even amplified
so here's another case study um
so north point is a company that
produces a software called compass that
assesses um whether someone is going to
commit a crime again
and so propublica this um nonprofit
organization that does some
investigative journalism
came out and said whoa whoa whoa you are
not being fair because given that an
individual did not reoffend black people
are twice as likely to be wrongly
classified as committing a of a higher
risk war than
white people her
but north pine the north point defended
themselves by saying that given a risk
score of seven
sixty percent of white people are
reoffended sixty percent of black people
are offended so
therefore it's it's fair
so
both of these actually turn out to be
simply different kind of desirada of
fairness and unfortunately there's some
actually impossibility results that say
you can't have
these two and a third criteria that hold
for imperfect classifiers at the same
time
and given that these algorithms are you
know being actually deployed and really
impacting people's lives in a
huge way this indicates that we not only
need to understand
the technical implications of all these
algorithms but also think about the
philosophical and policy related issues
as well
so this one's kind of scary generating
fake content
deep learning has enabled us to generate
deep fix such as obama saying things
that he never did which you can find
online
um or more recently this is a blog post
written by our friend gbt3 that was made
it its way to number one on hacker news
so it's completely clear at least to me
that we've lost the ability to gen tell
the difference between real and fake
content and given the ease and skill at
which fake content can now be generated
back to actors spreading disinformation
is i think a major threat to our society
finally ai systems are being deployed in
dynamic environments where you have
systems which are making predictions
serving you search results giving you
recommendations serving ads
and users are taking actions by
clicking essentially
and these actions are recorded as data
this data is used to retrain the system
which furthermore reinforces these
actions so i think there's a very
dangerous feedback loop inherent in
machine learning where all these biases
and are amplified and they're polarized
and leads to quite unstable behavior
so i think the major open research
challenges to how to figure out how to
build more robust systems that are
not as susceptible to these uh unstable
dynamics
so
to conclude
i just want to stress that ai technology
is an amplifier
and we've seen that ai can
and promises to
be quite beneficial to society reducing
excel accessibility barriers improving
efficiency
but on the other hand it can generally
amplify biases introduce new security
risk
centralized power
in ways that was kind of unprecedented
you know before
and i just want you to
keep these issues in mind as we go
through the course
just because you can build it doesn't
mean you should
and we could if we're not careful we
could potentially build something that
does more harm than good
and moreover figuring out the best way
to tread the line
between positive prospects and negative
risks is i think something that requires
a deep technical understanding
especially if we are to develop novel
solutions
and that's something that this course is
going to equip you with
so that concludes
this module